nikki what did he say to you when you
were on that call what do you remember
said that they found remains
and we knew it was gabby even though we
were hoping it wasn't but i knew she was
gone as a mom i knew she was gone gabby
petito's family is speaking out for the
first time about the 22 year old
vlogger's life legacy and tragic death
in an appearance on dr phil gabby's
father joe and stepmother tara and
mother nicole and stepfather jim all
gathered for a two-part interview where
they share the latest developments in
their daughter's case as the manhunt for
her fiance brian laundry continues jim
you had gone to wyoming and stayed there
because you felt like she was going to
be found there and you felt like
somebody needed to be there yeah it was
just something you know deep down that i
knew she was there you know and just
going off the
information that we had we felt that
somebody had to be there gabby's remains
were found late last month after she had
gone missing while on a cross-country
road trip with brian the family told dr
phil how they felt about brian's
disappearance and his unwillingness to
cooperate with the authorities after
gabby went missing you do know that he
came home without her and didn't tell
anybody it's infuriating we deserve
answers and you do know at least his
parents have said he did come home none
of you saw him in the house but you know
his parents said he came home
well that the van had to get there
somehow what's wrong he the van got
there
and whatever happened with his parents
after that i don't know but we can only
speculate we don't know cbs news
previously reported that brian had been
named a person of interest in gabby's
case but authorities weren't able to
speak with him on september 17 an
attorney for brian's family contacted
the fbi and said they had not seen him
since september 14th during the
interview gabby's parents slammed
brian's family over their handling of
their daughter's case and their own
son's disappearance and revealed they
repeatedly called and texted brian's
parents chris and roberta one of the
texts i mean i we're going to call the
police right you know just letting you
know because we have no idea no
responses
a normal parent when you
text someone that they're going to call
the cops because you can't find your
child they would reply
nothing no response no nothing we
actually thought they were both missing
at that point in time when we were
calling them i was worried about both of
them and when did you learn the van was
back the night of the 11th when i
reported her missing the detective came
to my door and let me know that the van
was in florida when asked if they think
brian is hiding gabby's parents seem
sure of it i mean is he an
environmentalist survivalist type his
nose is camping knows
i believe he bragged about that like he
was good at that stuff so he's likely in
the woods or the mountains or
somewhere somehow living that way
somewhere off the beaten path somewhere
just thinking he is not going to get
caught i guess as for any words they
have for brian gabby's family has one
message turn yourself in turn yourself
in turn yourself dressed
turn yourself in
let us have some closure
let us come to an end to this
tragic period
and just move on and be able to remember
gabby
for all the
wonderful memories we had with her while
the family awaits brian's capture they
are taking steps to move forward and
have already honored gabby's life
through one thing she loved tattoos
you all got a tattoo and i see here that
you've all got
on your arm let it be yeah yeah so let's
talk about this one first why let it be
it's kind of like her slogan you know
she's a big beatles fan and she's trying
not to harp on things all of them are
her tattoos she had this one on her and
she designed this one she was an amazing
artist
you